The more I've talked to neuroscientists
The more I've found out how little we
know about the brain you know I think we
know a lot about sort of the basic
chemistry of the brain how neurons fire
how chemical signals are sent and so on
and we know a furbit about big bits of
the brain their function in the overall
economy what we're almost clueless on is
how those big functions are realized at
the cellular level and I'd want to know
a lot more about that before I'm
convinced that we can reduce everything
that's going on to underlying chemistry
and physics and therefore there's no
free will so I think it's an open
question and I would say it seems like
we have free will and so in the absence
of any empirical argument one way or the
other I think we can tentatively believe
in free will